less than one percent of abortions  so so it's from the abortion clinic  okay do you have a different statistic  that you brought so or is this just  based on what you feel okay okay but so  it's based off of what it's based off of  what you feel so forty percent of women  that get abortions have had two or more  abortions  so it seems like it's just  you know that they're from grape well  because they're surveys they don't want  it they want to go on the topic they're  they're surveyed and it's less than one  person you're speaking as if it's  absolute facts you know why every single  person has one okay but you're you're  speaking as if you have any data at all  what they are  hold on